bad choices stare back at Musa every day
a nitrous oxide habit has left him
unable to walk
oh it's stupid
if you want to disable yourself carry on
even 12 year olds are misusing this drug
which is meant for pain relief in
hospitals
abusing it over time can lead to
life-changing injuries
started taking them daily because of
stress
which was obviously the dumbest thing I
could do
I was just taking them and then in the
middle of the night I go to the toilet I
got up and just fell on my face
I couldn't get up
you got it
Musa spends most of his day in bed his
body shakes his vision is blurred better
and he's lost feeling in his fingers and
toes
you won't know until it's too late it
makes you a crackhead make sure a bit of
a junker
I didn't pitch me being like this at 20
years old definitely not don't know how
I'd live if the outcome is I can't walk
again properly I don't know how I'd
react to that I swear to God
and this was musa's stomping
luminous and alluring Corner shops an
odd place one might think to find
nitrous oxide we're in Birmingham to see
for ourselves how easy it is to get hold
of nitrous oxide we've been given a list
of names of shops where we're told you
can get the canisters no questions asked
let's see
Eagle to sell nitrous oxide to anyone
over 18 but it is to supply it for
recreational use
our producer is wearing a hidden camera
yeah
how much
30 yes okay none of the shops check his
age nor do they ask what it's for
eign
here he's taken to a room at the back
is it in the back
okay
watch how the canister is bagged up for
him
yeah that's fine
and look at what the shopkeeper does
next
he gives us balloons
climate change
and in another shop you want this or not
like getting Cutlery with a takeaway
all but one of the stores we went into
simply handed over these canisters and
even though they didn't ask our producer
any questions they also handed over the
balloons used to inhale the gas from
these
[Music]
hail but ministers are calling for
tighter controls that could see more
prosecutions more fines and tougher
prison sentences what we don't want to
be doing is criminalizing users I don't
see how that helps the problem that's
going to drive it underground
um I think much tighter action needs to
be on the supply chain this stuff should
be so business to business it shouldn't
be sold in corner shops push up against
my hand Dr Nichols says he's seeing more
and more patients like Musa he calls it
a bigger problem than cocaine seeing
young people with completely avoidable
preventable neurological disability is
far from a joke it's really upsetting
and just pop your arms up like that for
us
spread your fingers this month the
government is set to start consultation
on the sale and use of nitrous oxide
even by the time they do musa's doctors
say it's unlikely he'll be walking again
Sadia chowdry Sky News